Having a hobby will give you depth to yourself
and stimulate your brain. Golf.
Am I good at it? No,
but it's fun and you get to wear cute little outfit.
Another option hiking. I used to live in Washington,
so hike all the time. I'm in Texas now,
so there's not that many hikes,
but if you like being outdoors,
try going on a hike, cooking a new recipe,
or baking. I have always been a person who loves cooking,
so if you want to get into cooking,
this is a really good hobby.
Reading. I love reading.
Anything from  Colleen  Hoover is literally magic to my brain.
Also painting, arts or crafts.
I love anything that I can be creative in.
This is, like,
really where I got my happiest,
when I can do my crafts. You might laugh and say this isn't a hobby,
but I think getting coffee at a new cafe or place is a hobby.
Along with trying a new restaurant.
That is a hobby. Okay,
understand that you're probably not depressed.
You just need something to stimulate your brain.